how would you describe the overall tenor
of the meeting and your takeaways it was
a good constructive meeting I thought
you know the Facebook senior leadership
was there they they really did Express
that they're worried about trust that's
just with conservatives that but with
people all around the country who might
be worried about being underrepresented
on their platforms and they wanted to
know what we were thinking and they they
told us some of the things that they're
thinking about doing to fix it from an
engineering perspective and we got some
feedback and it was it was good was very
interesting I have to say so on that
note then would you say that Mark
Zuckerberg admitted or indicated in any
way that there was bias in the trending
topics section no there never an
investigation that's ongoing and they
don't think that there's a conspiracy
and I'm sure there's not I mean quite
frankly it's implausible there's some
sort of conspiracy going on on this I
think that there because I don't think
that their conspiracies are hard to pull
off quite frankly and they're not very
profitable there's another thing to
worry about look there's 167 million
Facebook users in the United States and
they want to have a platform that
appeals to all different kinds of people
with different viewpoints having people
inside the company or in the leadership
god forbid that we're trying to shut
that down along some part of the
political spectrum would be a pretty bad
idea from business and that's not what
they want to do so I don't think that's
what's going on at all I don't think
anybody in the room thought that Ethan
crowd PAC released some data that eighty
nine point six percent of Facebook
employees are liberal in fact 50% of
them are more left-leaning than Bernie
Sanders does that matter I don't think
so I mean I think Facebook is probably
an overall reflection of both the
demographic of the people that work
there they very young employees are very
young company they're based in Silicon
Valley where overwhelmingly people are a
little bit left of center maybe maybe
right on par with Facebook's demographic
what I think's really interesting about
this story emily is it's sort of a it's
moving us closer to that line where
Facebook is acknowledging that they have
influence over us in very subtle ways
and everything I've heard the company
say is that they take that very
seriously and it sounds like they've
they reiterated that today but that's
something that we're gonna have to watch
I'm curious for the guests
are you did Facebook acknowledge that
did they say they they understood that
that what they put in their newsfeed has
influence over what people perceive yeah
well they talked about trust and trust
matters
it's everything when you're a media
organization obviously particularly one
that disseminates information without
trying to editorialize Facebook has no
ambition to become an editorial page
such that you don't want to identify it
with one particular point of view and so
this brings up the emily's last question
which is does it matter that liberal
points of view are so over-represented
from a national perspective at Facebook
and actually I think that it's a kind of
an interesting question I think it's a
big opportunity for Facebook as a matter
of fact I think that I I believe that I
could faithfully represent liberal
points of view even though I'm a
conservative but I think it would be a
good idea if to have more different
points of view in the room in the
community as a matter of fact and I
think that Mark Zuckerberg and Sheryl
Sandberg can can actually use this as a
major opportunity to have Facebook be a
forward leaning kind of company that
tries to represent Americans and you
know I think a more unbiased way simply
by getting more voices in the room now
there seems to be some tension here in
that Facebook is an independent business
organization and the Conservative Party
would say that you know the government
shouldn't you know ever interfere
interferes as little as possible so what
exactly do you really want from Facebook
oh I don't know what I particularly want
from Facebook they were asking my
opinion so it's not that I was going to
Facebook with some set of demands I have
no demands at all
I want free enterprise I want a great
company to be able to grow and serve
Americans better I mean that's that's
the the job of capitalism is as far as
I'm concerned they just wanted to know
what I thought they could do to make the
the situation go from something that's a
bit of a conflagration right now into an
opportunity and that's why I was there
and what do you think that they can do I
think that this whole idea of using this
as an opportunity to pivot to a
community that's more representative is
a is a big idea I think it's a big
entrepreneurial thing to do I mean if
you have a company in Silicon Valley
Silicon Valley is overwhelming
a left-wing place I get it it's also a
pretty non-religious place but people
who look at Facebook and and are relying
on it with their trending topics in the
news feeds they're not all like that and
and maybe this is a good opportunity to
try to build a community where people in
a civil and a respectful and friendly
way can and can understand each other's
points of view a little bit better and
in so doing maybe some of these types of
bumps in the road would be naturally
avoided